jacques lacan was the greatest French
psychoanalyst of the 20th century he was
also something that's come to feel
rather odd an intellectual celebrity as
much of a focus of gossip and curiosity
as a pop star he hung out with famous
artists and writers he had a fabulous
head of hair he attracted beautiful
women jacques mahi Emile laka was born
in Paris in 1901 his father was a
successful businessman a major figure in
the emerging soap industry his mother
was a pious Catholic his elder brother
became a Benedictine monk but lack I'll
stop ting in God at a young age he
became obsessed instead with philosophy
and mathematics at the age of 15 he
wallpapered his bedroom with pages torn
from Spinoza's ethics at university he
studied medicine and specialized in
psychiatry Lacan wrote many essays and
published transcripts of the seminars he
gave he liked to present his ideas in
highly complex ways and often deployed
mathematical equations and diagrams
he didn't write very clearly but beneath
the complex surface liqueur made some
extremely useful additions to our
understanding of ourselves Lacan was
deeply interested in an event that
occurs in the life of every child the
first time that they recognized
themselves in a mirror they have the
hugely distinctive and strange
experience which no dog or chicken has
ever had of looking at their own
reflection and thinking that is me
crucially the moment which lekar called
the mirror phase can feel very
unsettling because the face in the
mirror doesn't necessarily look as we
feel inside we are a formless continuous
stream of consciousness made up of
speeding thoughts desires and images we
are polysexual chaotic ever-changing and
ambivalent to the core but on the
outside we seem like a more or less
stable entity with composed and
symmetrical features that betray almost
nothing of what's going on within we
have only words to try to transcend the
gap and most of the time they fail to do
justice to our real intentions not
knowing how to say what we feel isn't
personal failing it's an existential
truth the image in the mirror is by
necessity far more one-dimensional than
the entity that beholds it this leads to
a problem that follows us throughout
life as adults we long for others to
understand us in the deepest ways but
luck is preparing us to face the darker
possibility that in fact other people
will be resolutely stuck on the outside
of us
assuming us to be pretty much as we seem
but heavily caricaturing us without
meaning to were understandably reluctant
to accept this loneliness and are
consequently very concerned to control
the external appearances that we present
that's what the fashion industry trades
on we hope that if we could think as
efficiently with what other people see
externally of us perhaps our hair or the
design of our collar we may eventually
be properly understood but lacquer
suggests a more difficult mature move
that we accept that other people simply
won't ever experience us the way we
experience ourselves that we will be
almost entirely misunderstood and will
in turn almost entirely misunderstand
Lakha was famous for his extremely
negative statements about romantic love
there is no such thing as a sexual
relationship men and women don't exist
and most dramatically man knows nothing
of woman and woman knows nothing of man
like I was trying to get an unpopular
yet critical fact about romantic
relationships the extent to which we
don't truly comprehend our lovers and
simply peg a range of fantasies drawn
from childhood experiences to their
physical forms it's a dark but in a way
liberating idea it invites us not to be
upset when we don't feel a perfect
rapport with someone who initially
seemed like a soul mate and it
recommends that we certainly don't rush
off in search of some more ideal partner
if we're feeling less than perfectly
understood the connection we worry that
we've lost is something we never
actually had our relationship hasn't
gone wrong through folly error or bad
luck it's following the ordinary path of
love which is to come to an awareness of
its own fundamentally illusory nature
with liqueurs help we can hold on to a
more accurate picture of what is normal
to be more or less always alone this is
a foundation upon which we can build
more mature and less frustrated
relationships
lekar was very active in intellectual
life in the late 1960s it was of course
a time of great excitement around social
change there was the sexual revolution
great interest in communism and lots of
protests lakhan's friends were extremely
excited Lacoste sympathized and yet when
he saw the increasing numbers of student
protesters he told them what you aspire
to as revolutionaries is a new master
and you will get one liqueur suggested
that though we believe ourselves to be
Democrats most of us have remarkably
interested in finding and then
worshipping authority figures who will
promise us the earth we desire to have
someone else in charge who can make
everything okay someone who is in a
sense an ideal parent and we bring this
peculiar sounding bit of our
psychological fantasies into the way we
navigate politics for Lakha the truly
talented politician isn't the one who
knows how to whip up the crowd and
ignites their semi-conscious childlike
dreams of perfection it's the one who
dares to be an adult someone who has the
skill to persuade people of the
disappointing nature of reality and who
has the tact to do so without provoking
unbearable rage and tantrums liqueur
never stopped trying to communicate a
very difficult fact what odd immature
and lonely creatures we are it's because
we refuse to recognize this and don't
budget enough time to absorb the grief
that we're more miserable than we need
to be lack are constantly tested new and
often unconventional methods to try to
make psychoanalysis a greater part of
our lives he saw it as the natural place
to wrestle with the conundrums of being
human he didn't like to call his clients
patients because he didn't want them to
think of themselves as sick or unusual
the only qualification for coming to
analysis was to be human like all
thought a session could be quite short
sometimes just five minutes if that's
how one happened to be feeling he even
allowed his barber and pedicurist to
visit while he was conducting analytic
sessions he wasn't doing this to be
provocative but rather because he was
interested in exploring how insights
might be delivered in a more relaxed way
so that they could reach many more
people Lacan was unafraid of me
intellectual truth with worldly success
and thought it was just as important to
influence politicians artists and
everyday people as it was to teach
philosophers or psychoanalysts he
continued a lecture around the world
right up until his death at the age of
80 though an atheist lekar had
occasionally spoken of a wish to have a
grand Catholic funeral
ideally either in Venice or Rome but it
wasn't to be
he was buried quietly near his country
house in the modest village of gotoku
not far from the northeastern suburbs of
Paris Lakha had big ambitions for
psychoanalysis he hoped that it might
transform the most powerful collective
bodies of the era like the Catholic
Church in a communist party and liberate
them from some of their errors he
believed that in the future
psychoanalysis would become widespread
and normal ingrained in the way people
think a part of the business of ordinary
life it's an important project and we're
still at it today
you